tony is in dallas hi tony welcome to the
ramsay show
hi good afternoon dave financing uh
thank you very much for taking my call
sure what's up i do have a question um
regarding
my mortgage and a situation i'm in i'm
just thinking about
kind of the future if i should save up
to refinance or just sell the home
currently on baby step number two um and
expecting
to hopefully pay that uh be out of debt
three by the end of this year
but right now we're not paused because
we're expecting the baby boy
uh in the late may good for you that's
wonderful thank you
thank you thank you and so right now the
only thing is
our home we have a 30-year term fha loan
with even down payment assistance um and
so
our payment is around 2200 with
income bringing in 5300 uh so that's our
monthly income coming in
so i know i when i first bought the home
i wasn't
into your apartment or anything like
that a couple months later that's when i
started hearing you and then i kind of
made a
oh situation i realized you know what i
got to live and learn
so now i'm trying to just find the best
way of doing going about this mortgage
tony is that 5300 gross or net
uh that is gross oh so you're bringing
in about forty four hundred
dollars net then no no no no no sorry
okay okay
okay and you said your house payment is
so much again 22 200. so it's close to
that
i mean 50 almost but um we are expected
an income increase uh in august
my uh my wife is going to complete her
teacher certification so
we're gonna see her income double what
other debt do you have right now tony
just fourteen thousand dollars of uh
student loans so what is her income
going to be then
what is your total household in wait i'm
sorry let me try this again what's your
total household income going to be
after she gets her certification so
after that whenever she gets her
teaching job which i think
we're hoping for august i'm thinking in
around 6800
from 6 500 6800 just defending the area
where she works
okay all right so that puts you at about
30 percent
yes so a little high and what do you do
for a living
uh and i work in insurance in insurance
yes so uh how much do you project your
income will go up over the next three
years
uh over the next three years hopefully
yeah right now
which is a good time i was thinking
about getting a part-time job
uh but right now since the storm's hit
in texas
i'll see they may pull me aside to do
overtime and help out in the claims
section
of our company so that's where i kind of
what are you doing there what do you do
in the insurance world
i'm actually a trainer so i train people
how to oh okay so you're not
you're not selling insurance so your
income's not following a sales pattern
okay so both of you are going to be
getting plus or minus this overtime
uh normal cost of living plus or minus
raises right
yes yes okay so you're going to be at 30
percent and dude
you're going to have it tight for a
couple years until it gets down to that
25
because your income continues to go up i
don't think the house is going to kill
you because her income is going to add
to the thing right now um but uh the the
main point of the 25
is if you're going to be there for 10
years yeah you're going to struggle
yeah if your house payments 50 of your
take-home pay but it's not going to be
but for a matter of months
yeah i agree yeah that's what i was
thinking as well i was just debating on
that
um i was like i know it's gonna be tight
enough for my life it's gonna be tight a
little bit yeah
and i get now with the 25 rule of why it
is
yeah so you know because you're feeling
you're feeling the pinch in your budget
right now
oh yeah yeah for sure let me ask you
this question
when you have the baby is she coming
home or is she still going to work
well she's still going to work well good
thing right now right we kind of planned
it this way
she's having the baby late may okay so
she's going to have the whole summer off
okay
uh with the baby and then i do i get
like six weeks paid time off so i'm
gonna take the first
probably the whole month of august off
while she goes back to work when
the new school year uh oh that's good
that's good so yeah
okay cool you got a plan so the point is
it's not a forever thing it's for a for
now thing
and the other point is for our listeners
we would not have signed you up for this
trip but you're going to be okay taking
it
okay that makes sense yeah hey man
thanks for the call